first thing I needed to talk to you
about is some very disturbing news I
learned about you yesterday you can't
stand the word pamphlet oh my god I'm
scared right then you can't stand
hearing it or can't stay insane I just
don't like I don't like it any any way
really cringey word okay I won't bring
it up for the rest interview okay so in
this movie so Maggie is you know
production assistant wanting to become a
producer I feel like there's a parallel
in your life because now you're moving
into the directing world a little bit by
doing the Coldplay video I know you said
you had to send in the pitch just like
any other director for that do you find
that gets tough for people to see you in
a different circumstance other than
acting um I don't know I think well for
that I just I wanted to I would wanted
to be the same as anybody else that was
pitching a video um and I think it's
sometimes difficult maybe for people to
to see me in a different in a different
way but also that's what kind of my job
is to be a different person and am I
trying to not really care what people
think that's a good way it was amazing
by the way congratulations on that now
in this movie we do hear you sing a
little bit so I would love to hear you I
do at least record a single recording
album would you ever consider doing that
not in in a million years why not you so
great oh my god no you will know the
piano right behind you I know I don't
know why that's there I will never be
releasing a Christmas album or anything
of that sort
okay now you've been around Hollywood
for a long time do you think this movie
is a good representation of what
personal assistants go through kind of I
think that in terms of working for an
iconic musician I'm imagine that that's
not some of the things that you get into
um it's it's it's an interesting thing I
think everybody has their own
relationship with the people that they
work with and I really like worship and
cherish the people that I work with and
some people treat them a bit differently
which I don't really get down with and I
think it's quite sad but I I mean this
is a wild industry and people are nuts
so and one of my favorite scenes in the
movie is one that scene in the border
with Tracy where she's hearing from all
these men you know what they should be
doing with a career and then the scene
you guys have in the bathroom afterwards
that is such a conversation we're having
in Hollywood you know with men telling
women what they should be doing with the
careers do you think that's changing now
in Hollywood I do in a in a way I think
that you know there's still some people
who have a lot of a lot of
decision-making power who have quite
old-school mindsets about things but I
do feel that thing that you know the
industry is becoming more welcoming to
different views of how movies should be
made or what movie should be made and
who is in them and what they're about
and that is something that I'm
supportive